it's time for the launching conosco a
television journal of the important
issues of the hour trot show you every
Monday Wednesday and Friday a
presentation of the lawn gene which nor
wats company maker of launching the
world's most honored watch and wit nor
distinguished companion to the world
honored lon gene good evening this is
frank night may I introduce our
co-editors for this edition of the
launch in chrome scope mister william
bradford huie and mr. henry hazlitt our
distinguished guest for this evening is
General Frank L Holly former first
military governor of brilliant well
general Holly you rose to fame and
Berlin when you talk tough to the
Russians and did so much to make a
success of the airlift in your new book
you answer some very important questions
and I'm hoping you'll answer some more
tonight I'd like to begin by asking as a
leading question do you think we're
going to win this war against Russian
communism yes I'm an American mr.
Haslett I'm not very good being a
pessimist well what do you think you'll
have to do to win it we'll have to make
up our mind that we want to win it
that's the first thing we have to do
well is there any general policy that we
have to change to win it have you been
following the wrong policy up to now yes
we have to change from the point of view
of getting an even break or a stalemate
into the idea of winning and that's very
American who ever heard of an American
who wanted to have a tie score in a
football game only sixty four dollar
question answer is can we win this war
without large-scale military action
I believe that we cannot win this war
without being prepared for large-scale
military actions in other words if the
Soviets can't have their way in any way
except to use force their use force and
they'll only use force if they have more
than a reasonable chance of succeeding
do you think we can get peace honorably
in Korea still or we get you think we
can get our objectives honorably in
Korea still we can't afford to do
anything which isn't honorable the honor
comes before peace it comes before
victory it comes before anything else
you can't have a great nation win lose
or draw if that nation is dishonorable
or if they make major sacrifices of
principle well you go along with the
idea that's been promoted recently that
the Korean should be able to take over
the whole front that we should train him
to take over the whole front withdraw
our own foot soldiers from Korea over
that period I'd say that was purely a
military decision but I will say that as
a general policy countries have to be
able to do their share or defending
themselves you can help them but any
country that values democracy will fight
for it and if they won't fight for it if
they aren't willing to go through Valley
forges and things of that sort I
question that they deserve to have
democracy general halle you've had
probably as much experience as any
American has directly with the Russians
and in figuring out how they think now
do you think that there is any
likelihood of their launching a war in
Europe and the near future there are
great reading minds that are trying to
work that out they'll only launch a
military operation in Europe if it's
going to succeed and they can't get what
they want in some cheaper way a bunch of
pamphlets is a cheaper way if they can
cause an internal revolution in iran
that's much cheaper than a military
operation and your feeling is that as
long as these cheap ways show results
they won't try more expensive ma'am
that's right and the more expensive
military operations are the less chance
they'll you what about the nature of
their military preparedness in Europe do
they have good divisions in in Germany
now for instance yes I would say that
they do have good divisions they
certainly have good divisions in terms
of 10 15 and 20 I don't believe that
their economy is such that they can have
unlimited numbers of crackerjack
divisions i don't think the intelligence
of their people gives them depth of
mechanics for example well do you think
the Germans can be trusted on our side
in the event of a showdown I don't trust
anybody too much I think we can trust
the Germans to do what is best or what
they think is best for Germany and we're
in the position that what is best for
Germany is a Germany live up to
agreements and stick with the west
rather than the east so that it won't do
the Germans much good to play hard to
get and try to play us against the
Russians or they won't do much of that
do you think oh they'll do that that's
the International bargaining they'll do
it the French would do it and I think
maybe we'd be smarter if we did a little
more of a sore back in back in nineteen
forty five and six sir I believe you
were one of the Americans who was trying
to make pacifist out of the Germans how
well did you succeed we succeeded fairly
fairly well and we were quite sincere I
mean we really believe that pacifism
would work and it's one of the tragedies
that due to the efforts of Russia we
have had to resume an assumption that
military operations may be necessary
that the policies that you followed in
1945 and six you think work we're
correct what was wrong was was russia's
attitudes yes and from our point of view
we were suffering under a great illusion
we thought the Russians were the kind of
persons we wanted them to be what do you
think the French will do that what we
expect open letter to say do you think
the French will really keep on preparing
and increasing their divisions the
French have a very
government and it always puts them in
the position where they make a promise
there can be no certainty that they'll
live up to it if they have to go to the
people for increased taxation as they
did after the promises at Lisbon the
government may very well fall and then
the agreement is passed by water
relation has this to the European army
idea this weakness of friends but as you
know from this latest book I'm a little
skeptical of this long-range idea of a
European army the integration is all
right if the units are big enough but
the original notion of small units of
different nationalities I think that
that was a good way to get licked
against an aggressive enemy now we have
the European army concept up two
divisions of one nationality still
rescue but at least that makes sense on
this recent trip of yours sir through
Europe did you find a rising field first
of unamerican of anti-americanism there
is a rising resentment I don't believe
it's really anti-americanism but it's
kind of a feeling that we're using our
money to tell them how to live well did
you also find a rising feeling of
neutralism in Europe more count me out
then who existed a few years ago that's
a bit spotty the Germans a few years ago
of course had this owner mec count me
out and according to Theodore Blanc
who's sort of responsible for whatever
rearming they do at the moment the
sentiment is unfortunately not without
me lighter own damn big in other words
they're getting a little more fatalistic
they don't want to join anybody's army
but well no more how about the internal
condition of the countries on our side
is communism gaining or losing in France
for example
in the first place the Frenchman doesn't
know he's a communist very frequently I
mean the one who is well the one who
wrote the Communist ticket he's
following the line or voting the ticket
I like I like specific cases it's like
an argument I had with the cab driver he
said he wasn't a communist but every
point of view we had he got out of
reading the Communist paper from the
point of view of circulation of the two
communist papers the circulation has
fallen of the morning paper humanity in
the afternoon paper says soir it's
fallen from about 800,000 doubt about
300,000 so that's indicative of a d
actual vote didn't fall much in
percentages over a period of four years
though did it it's pretty hard to tell
much about French voting is so
complicated well how about the Italian
situation on communism I don't believe
that I'd like to comment on the Italian
situation I don't I didn't visit their
this last summer and while I didn't do
any visiting in order to get new ideas
at least I checked up on my notions and
convictions and I didn't go down to
Italy among our own troops there on your
visit these six divisions that we have
in Central Europe are those good troops
what's the condition of our troops there
i'd say Monsieur e that our soldiers we
can be proud of them they look good
they're magnificent and behavior on
trains you can't tell the difference
between officers and Men there's a
well-dressed and thanks to the training
methods of recent years I believe
they're good combat soldiers of course
there's no no final test except combat
but they're given plenty of training is
there any reason why we should maintain
six divisions of troops in German and
now I think right now we have to yes but
I think you bet I think it's an unsound
position that Americans stand there
defending Germans let them fight their
own battle use the moment though we have
to have them there to give the French a
feeling that we won't back out on our
commitment you speak of a policy of
aggressive righteousness in your book I
believe now what do you mean by
aggressive righteousness general I mean
let's do what's right let's take
out and do the American thing the
principal thing and start with that and
then convince our allies that it's good
for them let's not start and set a
policy based on what we think we can
convince somebody that they ought to do
let's start off with the correct basis
of what is right now your book which is
titled your war for peace is getting a
good eve of attention sir what is the
purpose why did you write this book I
wrote it to cause the individual citizen
to think about our foreign policy and
and do you feel sir as a final question
do you feel that that we will ultimately
understand the nature of the enemy in
the nature of the war and that we will
ultimately win this struggle yes I do
and well sir thank you very much for
being with us this evening the opinions
that you've heard our speakers express
tonight have been entirely their own the
editorial board for this edition of the
lawn gene Cronus Cove was mister william
bradford huie and mr. henry hazlitt our
distinguished guest was General Frank L
hall a former first military governor of
brilliant